jänner um mein ziel ist es den
unterricht etwas interaktiver zu
gestalten
erst mal die motivation daher kommt auch
aus meinem unterricht man sieht es unten
links glaube ich ein bisschen ich
unterrichte medizinstudenten also der
unterricht ist ja naturwissenschaftlich
geprägte mehr fakten basiert was auch
häufiger mal zur frontalen phasen dann
führt was für die studieren sind auch
anstrengend ist und hat die mich sehr
aktiv sind
in diesem fall möchte ich jetzt die
aktivität mit kurzen text antworten
quasi erreichen man geht auch um in den
titel schon es gibt da sehr viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten das zu machen
ich würde das versuchen in den 20
minuten so einen kleinen einblick zu
geben
und mich dann auch recht unten schon was
ich so ein bisschen vorhaben also die
studierenden sollen diese antwort nicht
einfach neuesten mündlichen beitrag
geben sondern diese ist dann wirklich
ein tippen zum beispiel über einen
endgerät oder jetzt im online unterricht
auch einfach wenn man zwei das
browserfenster auf hat und dann hat das
tun was man jeweils benutzt dann nutzen
und erst kurze einleitung was vielleicht
alles schon kennen sind diese quiz tools
einem online funktionieren die sind auf
eigentlich bei unseren studierenden sehr
beliebt weil es noch ein bisschen unsere
klopft oder prüfungsfragen mit aufnimmt
also wir haben viele von diesen fragen
wo man die antwort du an kreuzen muss
also das eigentlich sehr beliebt ich
würde jetzt gerne anders machen und
weder text antworten benutzen also
business weiter führen dass die
studierenden wirklich eigene antworten
geben müssen
kurz zur einleitung noch was vorteile
auch wenn man digitalen tools benutzt
also einen vorteil allgemeinen die
studierenden werden erst mal aktiv und
der wunsch natürlich dass alle
studierenden aktiv werden also nicht
dass du immer die 234 klassenbesten sich
melden und dran kommen und natürlich
alle studierenden mitmachen können eine
zweite man kann auch einen teil
methodenwechsel quasi gleich einbringen
da ist dass die studierenden auch was
das smartphone in die hand nehmen müssen
entsteht eine neue situation dass auch
dadurch ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit erst
merkt
und der dritte punkt den ich auch sehr
wichtig finde ist dass die antworten
prinzipiell anonym gegeben werden können
und ich finde drittem einem kontext
nirgendwo beobachtet dass das glaube ich
die hemmschwelle bei vielen senkt sich
dann mit einzubringen
auf der anderen seite dann auch aus
sicht des dozenten man kann über die
tools sind auch den lernstand so ein
bisschen erfassen und setzt immer nicht
nur von den 234 besten sich melden
sondern von allen und man kann sich auch
durchaus darüber ein feedback dann
einholen
und ganz kurz die voraussetzungen also
um die studierenden brauchen sagen wenn
man es im präsenzunterricht macht hatte
man extra end gerät was aber mit dem
smartphone auch machbar ist was er die
meisten sowieso dabei haben
und irgendwie leben und brauchen in der
regel den account bereit ihn tun was man
benutzen möchte und natürlich entweder
hat man in der regel ja sowieso dabei
und was ich an der stelle gleich sagen
möchte ist vielleicht ein bisschen die
gruppengröße die man beachten sollte
also ist sie auf der rechten seite die
kann man auch sehr gut in sehr großen
gruppen noch einsetzen oder wenn er
seinen zahlen ergebnis einfach
ausgebildet wird bei den text antworten
muss man ein bisschen aufpassen wenn man
sehr große gruppen hat kann man damit
der menge einen text antworten die
eventuell kommen als dozent noch
wirklich umgehen in meinem unterricht
weihnacht zu gruppen von ungefähr 20
studierenden ich finde dass es noch eine
ganz gute größe wo man das dann handeln
kann
genau warum sollte es noch genauer
gleich gehen
also ich möchte diese textunes da
sozusagen einsetzen also ich möchte text
antworten statt quiz benutzen damit die
studie hat auch eigene antwort geben
müssen ich möchte es auch als mehr
schriftliche beitrag über diese tools
machen eben nicht als mündliche
wortmeldung mit den argumenten von eben
es ist anonym was war nochmal uns sehr
hilft und auch das einfach mehr an bord
meldung quasi einsammeln kann als dann
nicht nur einfarbig dann melden und
meine beispiele beziehen sich jetzt eher
auf kurze antworten es geht nicht darum
längere ausarbeitung und längere texte
schreiben
vielleicht zeigen exemplarisch einen
kleinen einblick in diese tools die es
gibt es gibt sehr viele tools ich würde
mich gleich auf das beschränken was die
fed beschrieben ist also das gibt den
küsten auch mit offenen frage typ oder
es gibt auch verschiedene cat tools weil
die von qsc und zu genannt werden erst
mit hauptsächlich machen und zwar kein
ausblick nur damit die zeit nicht
gesenkt und weitere komplexe so tust die
etappe zweitplatzierte
pinnwände nur so als im highlight einmal
kurz erwähnen
ich möchte euch einen kleinen einblick
in die funktionen geben und das auch ein
bisschen mit unterrichtsmethoden
verknüpfen dass er vielleicht gehen
könnte was man eventuell auch damit
machen kann
dann ist
weites feld für die nächsten minuten
ich habe mir jetzt nicht ausgesucht
heute ein bestimmtes hut zu nehmen das
einfach mal zu präsentieren und damit
euch zu machen soll ich habe mir
überlegt dass ein bisschen allgemeiner
zu andy
minimieren weil doch dieses zu so ein
bisschen unterschiedlich ist und ich hab
ja sagen die wichtigsten funktionen an
der stelle ausgesucht also wir sehen
hier ist in der mitte so ein user der
gleich mitmachen kann auf der rechten
seite ist so der moderator der
moderatorin die haben die kontrolle hat
denn das sehen wir was die ja vielleicht
noch machen kann und das linke fällt
sollte anzeigen was alle anderen
teilnehmer dann auch noch ihren
startpunkt werde jetzt wie tust ja warum
christoph zum beispiel so malte betreut
christ haben hier aber auch den christen
offene fragestellungen dann beinhalten
die funktioniert dann in der regel so
darf der moderator dann quasi eine frage
habt die kann auch schon vorbereiten
diese sendet er dann und anschließend
können dann alle teilnehmer das sehen
und wenn man die frage hat kann also
unsere jungs regierende antwort zum
beispiel ein geben und sagen okay ich
habe dieses leider schon mal benutzt das
ende ich jetzt hier mal ab
und dann bekommt es erstmal der
moderator nur die antwort die anderen
teilnehmer deswegen jetzt erstmal nicht
was man geantwortet hat und deswegen
auch charakteristisch für dieses tool
und jetzt können natürlich auch andere
teilnehmer noch ihre antworten
einschicken hat nur der moderator sieht
es erst mal aber die anderen teilnehmern
damit wollte kaymer mit laufen also
irgendwann endet das ganze dann
sozusagen
und im countdown läuft ab und erst am
ende werden dann für alle quasi die
kompletten antworten dann angezeigt und
gegeben
wozu kann
benutzen also wie in einem kleinen
beispiel zum beispiel einfach mal
vorwissen zu erfragen und so eine kleine
sammlung zu machen
für wiederholungs fragen also letzter
unterricht oder nach einer
unterrichtseinheit einfach dann fragen
stellen zur wiederholung
vorher fragen habe ich auch schon ganz
gerne benutzt im vorher fragen meint
prozent oder moderator stellt die fragen
von anfang ist unterricht schon mal die
studieren sollte aber nicht gleich
antworten sollen erstmals einen vortrag
zu hören und soll dann während des
vortrags nach dem vortrag dann die
arbeit die antwort geben also quasi eine
motivation bei dem vortrag etwas besser
zuzuhören oder
was man auch am antritt ende ganz gut
machen könnte ist so eine kleine
zusammenfassung
sie wird oft im methoden paypal und
blitzlichter fatale botschaft genannt
was so ein bisschen aus dass dadurch
eine kurze antwort eine
kurzzusammenfassung sein
was mir auch schon ein erstes beispiel
ein werk charakteristisch dass wenn man
der antwort gibt die anderen teilnehmer
erst mal nicht sehen was man anfängt hat
also in der summe ganz gut dafür
geeignet weil so wissensfragen wirklich
ab zu testen
das beispiel wäre dann ein einfaches
chat tool das so ein bisschen angelegt
auch was man so zum beispiel findet also
wo man nach der reihe nach quasi einfach
antworten dann posten kann
der staat wir dann hier das einfach der
moderator eine frage erst mal den raum
wirft also hier welche fragen gibt es
zum thema zum vortrag und dann können
anschließend dann die teilnehmer
antworten unserer user hat ja auch eine
frage sagt eben das leider gehört es
wieder wissen was ist das eigentlich und
postet das damals schon jetzt ist
charakteristisch dass eben alle
teilnehmer den post gleich sehen können
also ist man sich geheimnis tagen an der
stelle und die kann natürlich jetzt die
antwort an den ok war die gleiche frage
da muss ich meine frage ist gleich mehr
stellen anders kann man vielleicht auch
motive oder inspirationen gewinnen und
dann eigene fragen entwerfen andere
teilnehmer die jetzt noch wissen wollen
was ist eigentlich das model oder macht
es eigentlich dieses tablet
und das ist die summe erst mal ganz gut
geeignet wenn auch um was sie fragen zu
sammeln vielleicht auch ein
brainstorming einfach zusammen quasi
ihren wissen zusammenzutragen sagt man
sieht immer gleich was die anderen
gepostet haben
viele von diesen tools haben dann noch
eine kleine extra funktion eingebaut und
zwar wenn man sich noch weiter
diskutieren möchte vielleicht an diesen
ergebnissen und vielleicht eine
rangfolge festlegen möchte also was
macht beim anstoß sich etwas genauer
diskutieren dann bieten diese tools oft
solche like button an
also unser user hier zum beispiel möchte
jetzt gerne weiter über das pad lettern
reden der würde dann hier auf den button
drücken das funktioniert leider meine
animation nicht ganz so gut dass wir
dann markiert werden und manche tool zur
tier sortieren dann sogar anschließend
auch noch die reihenfolge quasi wieder
neu also dazu sagen die bestbewertete
antwort ein ganz oben steht also die
möglichkeit das ganze auch noch mal zu
gewichten
die sie dazu sagt charakteristisch man
sieht sofort was die anderen gepostet
haben
wurzeln könnte man das einsetzen also
auch um fragen während oder nach einem
vortrag zu sammeln ich habe auch gleich
seinen daumen hoch button daneben
gemacht weil ich das schon ich finde im
erfolgreich bei referaten eingesetzt
haben
also wenn studenten mit der verrate
gehalten hat ist oft sehr schwierig
vielleicht fände es auch manche
anschließend fragen eine diskussion
anzuregen ich hab das tool genutzt so
sagt die schreibt eure fragen halt in
dieses tool rein und ich glaube eben
gerade aufgrund der anonymität die dann
entsteht hat das sehr gut funktioniert
alles sind deutlich mehr fragen und
deutlich mehr aktivität gekommen als
wenn man das ganze dann mündlich wenn
man quasi vor dem publikum macht
man könnte ein brainstorming machen in
der nicht ganz gut dass man halt die
anderen post gleich sieht und dann quasi
dann assoziativ mehr antwort und neue
antworten daran dann findet man
könnte auch wir vorher irgendwo wissen
abfragen da sieht man auch die tut sind
es nicht ganz unähnlich also man kann
die durchaus dann in verschieden da in
richtung auch benutzen
feedback einholen funktioniert auch
nicht ganz gut da ich wieder vorteilhaft
dass mit der anonymität also dass die
studierenden einfach eine geringere
hemmschwelle haben warum dort antworten
reinzuschreiben
und das könnte mal wieder ähnlich
benutzen um einfach am ende der stunde
zum beispiel eine kleine zusammenfassung
von einzusammeln also was fandet ihr gut
was habt ihr nicht verstanden wo sie das
nächste mal weitergehen man kann schnell
und gut eigentlich also keine sammlungen
damit machen
dann würde ich auch gleich zum dritten
beispiel kommen ich habe
ein bisschen aufgeräumt aber die fragen
von eben stehen dann noch jetzt kommt
dazu dass viele von diesen tools im chat
noch die question und ämter
möglichkeit eingebaut haben also dass
man diese fragen dann oder die beiträge
direkt beantworten kann das klingt jetzt
zum beispiel über die chat funktion
uns wundert direkt hinaus
das muss dann in der regel vom moderator
kann sie aktiviert werden aber der
kleine tier sehen ich aktiviere mal die
antwortfunktion dann kommt zu allen poes
hat die möglichkeit dass man sie direkt
beantworten kann und wir sagen wir hier
unser user sehr drückte wieder auf
antworten kann dann da wieder eine
antwort
anschließend ein tippen kann die
absenden und
anschließend erscheint genau unter dem
posten am ende das also diese jets eine
gewisse ordnung auch gekommen und auch
jetzt mal eine frage beantworten will
die halt die weiter entfernt steht im
chat dann kann man die antwort direkt
darunter posten also in der summe
deutlich geordneter als wenn man einfach
nur die zeitliche abfolge der posten hat
so kann man das benutzt also man kann
natürlich zu fragen wie zum beispiel im
vortrag dann auftauchen auch direkt an
antworten darunter schreiben ich mache
dann aber habe es auch schon gemacht
dass ich diese fragen die auf geworden
aufgeworfen wurden von den studierenden
selbst habe beantworten lassen also die
sollten dann erst mal beginnen die
antworten darunter zu schreiben also ich
hab dir einfach erstmal gar nicht
aufgelöst
bei einem brainstorming was ich jedem
angesprochen könnte man jetzt darunter
quasi weitermachen und weitere
unterpunkte sammeln man könnte pro und
contra argumente sammeln also jeden
punkt denn auch noch weiter ausführen an
der stelle
dann habe ich auch schon genutzt und ein
feedback einzuholen das habe ich links
mache aus vergrößern und zwar was dann
so dass ich den ersten post immer
gemacht habe und ich habe dann drei
quasi fragen oder kommentare schon
hingestellt und gesagt bitte gibt meine
antwort was habt ihr inhaltlich was habt
ihr methodisch aus dem seminar
mitgenommen und gibt auch mehr wird ein
kleines feedback und deren die
studierenden konnten passend zu diesen
fragen genau an der stelle halt wenn
dann drunter ihre antworten schreiben
war es wieder das ergebnis hat das ganze
ein bisschen portierte dann ausschaut
und jetzt noch ein weiteres beispiel zum
beispiel die methode erwartungs analyse
anbeginn vom seminar davon im workshop
man vielleicht erwartungen abfragen
möchte auch das könnte man hier zum
beispiel realisieren dass man also vier
hauptpost erst mal hinsetzen welche
erwartet habe habe ich an seminar an die
lehrenden an die gruppen und auch an
mich selbst und die teilnehmer können
hat passend zu den fragen das direkt
unterscheiden und man hat eine gewisse
ordnung dann schon in den ganzen
und dann kommen vierte variante also
immer noch im chat und da bieten manche
anbieterin an dass man diesen chat auch
noch moderieren kann was bedeutet
erstmal moderation wir haben ja eine
frage die der moderator erst mal
allgemein in den raum reinstellt und
unser teilnehmer hier hat sie eine
antwort tipp die 1 schickt die art und
jetzt muss der moderator diesen post
aber erst noch freigeben also den hier
auf der linken seite die anderen
teilnehmer sehen erst noch nicht was da
geschrieben wurde sondern erst wenn der
moderator freigibt für das erscheint
jetzt haben noch andere teilnehmer auch
ein paar einträge geschickt dann nackt
die anderen sehen die holz nichts davon
nur der moderator kann quasi erst mal
sammeln und das ganze anschauen
nutze nichts wenn ich schon mal das
erste gleich ein also jetzt erstmal der
moderator gesagt okay frage 2 mit ss
freischalten das ist zwar zu meinem
fordert wiederholungs frage da möchte
einmal etwas genaueres wissen das möchte
ich zuerst sprechen uns die frage erst
mal was in den raum stellen dann kommt
vielleicht die unterste frage die ich
noch ein bisschen weiter führen welche
kosten gibt es zum beispiel und dann die
oberste frage an was ist euch das beste
tool ist ein bisschen fett abgefahren da
hier eine andere meinung das diskutieren
wir quasi ganz am ende werden die
diskussion fängt auch ein bisschen
wilder wird
welche möglichkeit wozu gibt es darf das
ganze ist sicherlich auch erstmal eine
sicherheitseinstellungen dass also der
moderator auch die möglichkeit hat quasi
ungewollte trost quasi aus zurück tieren
also die jeweils ich irgendwie nicht
passiert sind die diskriminierend sind
oder sonst was wobei ich sagen muss dass
ich das bei meinem unterricht noch nicht
gemerkt habe dass so ein fuß mal
vorgekommen werden kann man das ganze
aber auch didaktisch nutzen aber zum
beispiel ein beispiel man kann sie das
diskutieren und beantworten ein bisschen
damit lenken dass der moderatorin
entscheidet welche frage ist überhaupt
sichtbar und in welcher reihenfolge
möchte ich diese fragen jetzt eigentlich
beantworten oder auch wie viele fragen
möchte ich eigentlich beantworten
und man hatte ich natürlich noch mal die
möglichkeit wie wir es ganz am anfang
bei diesem offenen frage im quiz quasi
gesehen haben die teilnehmer sehen und
kann man da erst mal nicht das
eigentlich gepostet wird also man kann
auch mal ein bisschen business fragen zb
absagen also man kann quasi nicht mehr
abschreiben sozusagen und die antworten
übernehmen jeder teilnehmer muss
erstmals für sich selber denken und
schreiben und erst dann quasi zeigt man
dass alle teilnehmer quasi gemacht haben
also was eigentlich typisch für den chat
dass alle gleich alle sehen das würde in
dieser variante dann wegfallen
dass meine vier grund beispiele ich ganz
gern präsentieren wollte zu diesen
relativ einfachen tools eigentlich also
man kann es eigentlich alles quasi über
einen anbieter tool erreichen die haben
oft dieses schlüssels mit drin auch mit
den offenen fragen und die bieten in der
regel dann auch diesen chat auch mit
dieser presse und ernsthaft funktion
habe ich für euch eine kleine tabelle
gemacht und kann ein überblick wo man
die unterschiede vielleicht nochmal
sehen kann also ein hauptunterschied war
bei der offene frage sehen sie anderen
teilnehmer erst mal nichts was gepostet
wird beim jetzt sieht man es halt man
kann dann hat die antworten posten bzw
die durch die like button das meint der
punkt hier auch eine gewichtung nach
reihenfolge dann festlegen
unten ist erst mal angedeutet ich halte
das für den synchron und rechtlich sehr
geeignet um teilnehmer auch teilnehmen
zu lassen
können asynchron unterricht ist
vielleicht nicht so gut geeignet also
man kann sich einen chat auch öffnen
wenn alle andern 2 zu hause sind und
dann schreiben lassen aber die tools
sind sicherlich erstmal für den synchron
unterricht gedacht
so und dann wieder in der mitte hier
noch so viele quasi rote kreuze das
zeigt so ein bisschen der zivilisierung
von diesen tools an
wir haben das schon gesehen wir können
so eine gewisse reihenfolge bzw eine
gewisse ordnung im quasi ihr bekommen
man kann aber mit dem was gepostet wurde
anschließend nicht mehr wirklich
großartig weiterarbeiten das ganze neu
zu arrangieren
nochmal zu ab zu erinnern wird dann
schwierig und das zweite was ein
bisschen limitierend ist viele von
diesen tools erlauben es auch nicht
dateien zu kosten also der chat hierbei
sind zum beispiel da kann man dateien
rein posten das gibt es bei vielen von
diesen anbietern ein entsprechend nicht
deswegen würde ich das gerne so kleiner
ausblick dann nochmal zeigen welche
tools können dass eventuell wo kann man
jetzt weiterarbeiten wenn man noch mehr
sagen mit diesen antworten machen möchte
und ich versuche es kurz zu machen und
auch nur zu sagen bisschen sieht einmal
zu nennen das erste während dieser pads
vielleicht hat das schon mal gern gehört
damit gearbeitet im prinzip ist quasi
ein erholt dokument oder format was man
über einen link dann bekommt alle
teilnehmer können da hingehen und
gemeinsam kollaborativ quasi einen text
schreiben oder bearbeiten also alle
können gleichzeitig quasi auf der seite
seine noch gleichzeitig schreiben auch
da könnte man bei einem brainstorming
einfach punkte quasi erst mal sammeln
und was wenn der vorteil von diesem text
to lift man kann natürlich an diesen
deutlich besser dann weiterarbeiten man
kann die texte ergänzen man kann sie
umstellen man sich auch um essen zu
allgemeine textur funktionen da also man
kann dann die texte quasi besser aus
arbeiten also dann wenn man einen
längeren text formulieren möchte
nächste möglichkeit im das whiteboard
ich denke dass kennen alle ich sage gar
nicht allzu viel dazu
also die möglichkeit aber natürlich text
zu tippen man kann natürlich zeichnen
und malen man kann bei manchen anbietern
auch bilder rein posten also schon etwas
mehr optionen überhaupt erstmal und das
schöne beim whiteboard natürlich dann
man kann es an ganze auch noch mal um
organisieren man kann hier
sachen an verschiedenen neu anordnen man
kann verbindung mit pfeilen herstellen
also man kann das ganze von den räumlich
besser anordnen und quasi weiter
ausarbeiten
und das gleiche führte auch zur für
diesen pinnwand tools vielleicht gelten
das pendelt ist dabei spielt das
bekannteste von allen
auch da hat man folgen die möglichkeit
erst mal bilder zu posten man kann links
und auch dokumente reinstellen also
besser deutlich besser geeignet wir
haben wenn man also mehr an dokumenten
dann sammeln möchte wenn diese pinnwände
kann man dann oft in so spalten einfach
anordnung quasi oben den titel drüber
schreiben und dann die post zu sagen wie
im chat auf darunter posten nur dass man
das ganze als deutlich besser sortieren
kann man kann es auch um arrangiert und
man kann die sortierung ändern und
dadurch natürlich auch anschließend
deutlich besser das ganze nochmal
bearbeiten oder auch verarbeiten
und deswegen habe ich zum abschluss das
quasi auch nochmal mit aufgenommen in
meine tabelle also auch diese
ausführlichen tools die haben quasi die
grundfunktion im prinzip auch mit
eingebaut nun kann man die vorteile dass
man dann etwas besser wer dateien
einfügen kann und das natürlich am ende
noch etwas besser damit sortieren oder
gruppieren dann anschließen kann und am
ende sind sie noch deutlich besser für
einen quasi synchron unterricht geeignet
also man kann dann auch nicht präsenz
fahren daran weiterarbeiten und war sie
auch längerfristig damit dann arbeiten
und dann ich meine grund eigentlich erst
mal durch und ich würde euch sozusagen
die tabelle erstmal so als take home
office bzw ansatz für fragen dann stehen
lassen